how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some really big and exciting
news today about the Fox characters that
Disney now owns coming into the MCU and
according to reports the first
characters that are going to be entering
the MCU from the Disney Fox Deal are
going to be the one and only Fantastic
Four and according to reports they're
actually going to be coming into the MCU
a lot sooner than we thought so I'll
break down this news about the Fantastic
Four in this video but first if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
I'm doing a giveaway at four hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers I will be
picking three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection all you have
to do is be subscribed to my channel
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so with the Disney
Fox deal done a lot of people thought
that we were going to have to wait a
very long time for the x-men and the
Fantastic Four to enter the MCU
especially since Kevin Feige said that
it would be a very long time until we
saw the x-men into the MCU however he
did not say anything about the Fantastic
Four and according to a report from the
gww Marvel is planning a Fantastic Four
reboot for 2022 that's only three years
away and it would be in phase four and
according to this report the film may
already have a director as Peyton Reed
who directed the ant-man films has been
pitching Kevin Feige his idea for the
movie this would be great news because
not only did Peyton Reed do a great job
with the ant-man films but he has been
pushing to direct a Fantastic Four movie
since 2003 he actually pitched his idea
for the movie back to Fox when they
owned the rights in 2003 but
unfortunately they weren't interested at
the time his pitch for the film would be
set in the 60s and would involve two
quantum realm and possibly the Black
Knight here's what Peyton Reed had to
say about his Fantastic Four reboot idea
in the past visually one of the things
we always talked about and this was 2003
was the Fantastic Four as daytime
superheroes they don't have secret
identities they're very much a part of
the fabric of Manhattan in that universe
if you go to New York to the Empire
State Building or to the Statue of
Liberty or the Baxter building
it was all a part of that we talked
about if being a 60s period movie but
Fox at the time was now
into it the movie is also said to skip
the origin story of the Fantastic Four
so in the movie the heroes will already
have their powers and Marvel already has
three release dates for their films in
2022
February 18th May 6th and July 29 right
now February 18th is rumored to be
Captain Marvel 2 in May 6th rumored to
be guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so that
would mean according to this report that
we would be getting a Fantastic Four
reboot on July 29th of 2022 again this
is great news because we all thought
that we would have to wait at least five
years to see any characters from Fox
into the MCU but apparently we will only
have to wait three years until we see
the Fantastic Four into the MCU so let
me know how excited you are to finally
see the Fantastic Four come to the MCU
and let me know which actors you think
would be good to play the roles let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again a reminder about my
giveaway at the 450,000 subscriber mark
I will be picking three winners and each
will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection one
winner from the 400,000 giveaway has
already gotten their prize so be sure to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so you can enter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your